my daughter's 9 I'm driving her back
from my brother my brother-in-law's
place yesterday and she's it's 10:00 at
night is she staying that way bad so bad
why she was having too much fun and
she's talking up a storm
she's just tossed out of Kathy chatta
chatta but it's not it's not like her
yes she's asking me questions she got
the coach you talk to me
no no bro she wasn't doing lines man
she's 9 bro I don't know no you're
missing the point of the story
don't with no sire don't drug in robbing
the derale the thunder dragon right nine
year olds are doing cook so she's
talking to me at a honey I'm like what's
going on you're right because I'm just
talking to you I go oh so what else
daddy tell me a story tell me sorry and
I'm like what's going on are you alright
and just no I just need to talk to you
so you stay awake and I go did auntie
Kathleen tell you to talk to me she goes
yeah I said what'd she say said he said
if I don't talk to you the whole way
home you might fall asleep and we could
crash and die hey Kathleen don't tell my
daughter that the poor thing is like
she's exhausted but she's up telling me
stories she'll ask me questions she's
actually listening to my advice which I
was like this is weird this is weird she
never listened so I asked Joe to go
because she was living in Hacienda
Heights kind of far from there I'm like
let me just take out a date she's
working for the UFC at the time she's
like you know you know I'll lose my job
they find out like it wasn't right I
remember this house like no one's gonna
find out so I was just kind of new to
California I saw Brian like wish I
figure his bro
take her to Joe's off a bit Kenny it's
amazing I'm like oh hell yeah I'm like
20 reservations now I should be good on
him whatever Thursday night Friday night
I pull my pole I pee or she meets me up
place right opened my car door like a
gentleman sit her down drive to Abbot
Kinney
we pull up to it I'm telling how great
this restaurant is I'm just
regurgitating when town told me about it
like I've been there before we pull up
and it's closed and I went I played off
when it died say Joe's nuts this one and
there's some random yeah somewhat random
one next to it but then something happen
like at the time at a BMW m6 and she had
this expense
like Weaver Tom person all her stuff
like you let me to bring that inside
just leave it here I did something on my
car right like don't click the button so
this is off habit Kenny late at night it
rolled all the windows down like the car
so she comes back to us oh my god I'm
like wat in her purse is sitting there
so when someone stole my purse
and also tries even with on the first
night didn't heart that was the reason I
liked her we start talking when I sign
this guy this guy literally it's like
I'm just trying to hang out man look I'm
sorry that I rattled your brain I'm
sorry wasn't about Gucci's my brain
don't wear shoes with buckles on them
stop talking to me
you've lost all credibility you [ __ ]
pilgrim you all [ __ ] pilgrim hey you
gotta save this [ __ ] for your friends
you're out you know who he's like bro I
started laughing what are you doing I
know you know you go like this you go
yeah I go am i boring no no you're not
I watched the whole talk with John
Einstein aware went over in detail so to
have you skim through it is painful no I
black I also went to school like we
covered Einstein yeah but so for you to
go for it I hear your brother you know
I'm saying I was just telling you a
story about who he had an experience
which chained redefined our reality but
you were I can't talk to you right now
anyway because you have Oh bro you have
Bob yes there's no but you should do it
all on X time it just like you tell me
at once hey guys this is all things
Einstein hey guys what's the deal with
the theory of relativity and as you know
he had to refocus his energy on light
being part of me just wanted your boys
and then you were just wouldn't shut up
by I sound like dude haven't seen you a
few days and you were just I know I love
Weinstein as much of the next guy let's
just hang man you know wife's Latin yeah
yeah fully thick accent I'm sure she
wants kids
Oh bro we got married five years ago
next month and at the wedding I look ito
with d6 and I'm working on it I'm
working but they're like where are your
where are they mean yeah you're too old
you'll be a heat oh yeah we need we need
you know and it's just like oh and she's
Catholic - dude - st. my god
Guadalajara man and is that right yeah
yes you are you did you did the job we
have fulfilled your purpose we need more
now oh is that right he want more more
they want a little girl they want a
little prince this is your wife speaks
Spanish oh I'm like a refugee in my
house it's it bro
well I struggle is super real and I
speak zero and I don't get it I think
it's the brain trauma but I've watched
every morning since he was born he's 18
months now 18 months i watch the Spanish
cartoon every morning I do that I don't
understand [ __ ] I got nothing
see here's how it works for me I sit
down with rosetta stone like a [ __ ]
gorilla trying to finger paint
El Nino cordray anemia baby Yeah right
just just simply and so what happens is
my wife like if she's not talking to me
or working she does not speak English
right
like all her friends Latins Oh Zak's
okay and the TV when I get up in the
morning we actually buy the [ __ ] from
Colombia so she can watch news about
Bogota in the ocean
yeah she's Colombian yes we watch the
news from Colombia in the morning we get
home
watch the Colombia I don't know what's
going on DC but I can tell you all the
bow is Colombia yeah yes it's so so what
happens there she was right it was like
well I'll travel in song lyrics did she
sure works it out with me I'm not
confident enough to really try beer on
my family cuz yes I you know I'm gonna
sing you know if here's the thing people
like if you speak a language [ __ ] up
people will judge your intelligence but
it's really just your command of the
language is what's just it's a piece to
learn again I've been I've balls-deep in
Mexican culture it's my thing in Israel
here's the here's the here's the key
question for you where is the
mother-in-law the mother is she she's an
hour from me and she's so yes that's the
relevant action grandma yeah no were
like she's like my girls here because
she's working for Fox Deportes covering
the fight oh really yeah oh cool yeah so
we're like a super low budget Beyonce
super-low 90 watt power come yeah yeah
I'm super low level yeah so she's here
cover it and the kid you know my son
goes with the grandma I mean she's
that's cute that's gonna set him up for
life for like we've already said like
you know whenever we have a kid summers
just gonna put that little one 200%
bogotá and you do not speak English